we are learning new details about what
president-elect joe biden plans to do in
his first days in office they include
rolling back some of president trump's
best-known policies
weisha zhang is covering the biden
transition in wilmington delaware and
joins us from there
good morning to you we they have a lot
planned on the very first day
they do gail they're going to get right
to work this weekend president-elect
biden spent it
working on his inaugural address which
will aim to tackle
bridging the gap of a deeply divided
nation and you're right
he has announced an aggressive plan for
his first 10 days
in office on day one as president mr
biden plans to reverse the trump
administration's ban of travelers
from some muslim majority countries
rejoin the paris climate accord
and mandate mask wearing on federal
property and during interstate travel
among other policies
he also plans to extend the pause on
federal student loan payments and
continue
protecting people from evictions and
foreclosures
all those actions mr biden can do
unilaterally
but he does need congress to achieve
other goals
namely passing a 1.9 trillion dollar
coveted relief
package and getting cabinet nominees
approved but
senators will likely also be juggling
president trump's
second impeachment trial tony we should
thank you very much